so two years ago i made a game in an
hour using hazel my game engine this was
inspired by dany making a game in one
hour using unity i basically wanted to
make the exact same game that he made in
unity but in hazel that way i could kind
of like see first of all what it would
even be like making a game because back
then hazel was like in its infancy i
mean it had barely any features and so i
kind of spent a lot of that time that i
had to make the game making like the
actual engine like filling in the gaps
of what was missing in the engine that
of course far from ideal and i mean that
not only meant that i couldn't actually
physically make the same game because we
were missing things like audio and
physics it meant that the precious time
that i did have was not spent using the
engine and making the game but spent
like trying to trying to like implement
some weird like collision
detection thing to to make it playable
and hack like some bloom in there by
adding glow in photoshop i mean it was a
disaster now however
it has been two years
and lots has changed in hazel and so i
thought that i would do the exact same
thing again so that we can see how far
hazel has come however
a few things are going to be different
this time okay so first of all 2d
nah let's make a 3d version of this game
instead one hour time limit
i mean i like that idea it's nice to
have like a finite amount of work for
yourself like i don't want this to go on
forever so i think maybe something that
is theoretically possible content-wise
to create within an hour is a good
starting point however i don't want to
just
set a timer start the game and then stop
the timer
and then make sure that's within an hour
i want this to be chill and so whilst i
will have a timer running and i'm going
to try my best to kind of fit the actual
work within that hour block i'm not
really going to be counting time that i
spend like thinking tweaking things
playing the actual game because i might
want to like play it a few times as i go
to make sure everything's working i'm
not really going to be timing that much
i think the actual game itself
is definitely something that should be
possible to complete in an hour or a
little bit more i'll have the original
video linked up there by the way check
that out so that you kind of know what
i'm talking about and what the original
game was so to summarize i'm going to
aim for like an hour of actual work
rather than an hour of time past since i
begin the project and finally the third
thing that is different is hazel now
comes in two flavors there's hazel and
there's hazel 2d now in that video two
years ago i effectively used hazel 2d i
use like the game engine series version
of hazel that's all cool but now i want
to bring out the big guns i want to
actually use like the full version of
hazel if you have no idea what i'm
talking about why there are two versions
what hazel even is then definitely check
out the hazel website hazelengine.com
there's like an explanation there that
explains what each version is and
why we're even building a game engine
speaking of which did i mention that
this website is hosted by hostinger the
sponsor of today's video no well it is
and hosting it is by far the best web
host i have ever used no matter who you
are you need a website let's be honest
the world revolves around the internet
hostinger is a platform that provides
you with a server that you can use to
put something on the internet a website
would be an example of something to put
onto the internet there are plenty of
other websites platforms companies you
could go to to get your web hosting done
but the thing that i really like about
hostinger is the fact that it is
extremely affordable for the quality
that you receive this doesn't feel like
a cheap web host by any means their
platform is really really solid their ui
is fantastic they have amazing tutorials
and documentation to get you started and
answer all of your questions and did i
mention that it's easy to set something
up i mean this literally right here is
what it took for me to set up hazel
engine.com and i set that up as a vps
rather than a simple shared hosting
server because i have special plans for
that website
hostinger.com is the link in the
description to check out go ahead and
sign up for one of their plans and give
it a go if you use the coupon code
cherno at checkout you will receive an
even bigger discount it's the holiday
season right now it's like the perfect
time to actually sit down get a moment
to set up your website and meddle with
the internet so definitely give hosting
a go i promise you you won't be
disappointed i've been using them for
the last few years and they've been
amazing huge thank you to hosting it for
sponsoring this video and a lot of what
we do with hazel to be honest all right
we've got a game to make let's get to it
okay so the first step is to open hazel
we actually have this great launcher
that we can use now to create a new
project this is kind of new we actually
didn't have this up until a few months
ago before that we had to basically copy
an existing project and then like modify
it so this is pretty cool now once we
open the project it will open up in
hazelnut which is the hazel engine
editor we have this blank scene here and
all i'm gonna do is basically set up
like a basic skylight and a camera so
that we can hit play and actually see
something during this video i'm
obviously going to speed up certain
sections but i'm not going to cut
anything so you guys will actually see
every action taken to build this game
and its assets in hazel and whatever
other software i use once we've got a
basic scene set up i wanted to go into
blender and actually create this 3d
rocket now i did have like the original
rocket design that danny made and then
the one that i made with the cherno logo
on it as a guide so i kind of just
followed that and made it out of some
basic primitives like this cylinder the
cone i gave it a few materials of course
and then i uv unwrapped the cylinder
because i wanted to position that cherno
logo on it as a little signature like i
did in the original 2d game i did a
little bit more tweaking and then i
exported it in the gltf format hazel
also supports fbx and that's mostly what
i've been using thus far but i've been
trying to kind of switch to using gltf a
lot more once we have that we can drag
it in as a static mesh into hazel and
here i'm just adding a directional light
playing around with it seeing what looks
nice now i also added this kind of like
burner area that i wanted to give an
emissive material to so here i am
creating that emissive material inside
hazel and assigning it to the burner
material so that we get this nice glow
now emissive materials of course don't
actually emit light they just work with
the bloom effect so what i'm doing here
is actually creating a point light
parenting it to the rocket and then
putting it in like place of the burner
so that we can actually get light
emitting from that burner next i'm going
to add a rigid body and a capsule
collider to the rocket so that we can
actually get some kind of physics and
collision detection now i'm actually not
really planning to use the physics
system to do the actual like rocket
movement i'm going to basically recreate
the same movement mechanics that i
created in the original game that way i
have a little bit more control over it
and also it's a simple game it doesn't
really require a physics simulation i
care a lot more about the feel of the
game than an actual like realistic
physics simulation and here i am
simulating the actual physics and then
playing the actual game so that we can
see that rocket fall down now next up i
want to introduce some behavior and
interaction into this game so i'm going
to the project directory and opening up
the visual studio solution that hazel
generated now hazel uses c-sharp for
scripting so a lot of this actual
scripting is going to be a lot like
unity and way less than what it was like
in the original 2d game that i made a
couple years ago since that was entirely
written in c plus so this is another
huge step forward what i'm going to do
here might be slightly controversial
however i'm actually going to look at
the game that i made two years ago
and basically steal a lot of the code
from there i just kind of want to make
it feel more or less like the same game
or at least use that as a starting point
now a lot of it of course will need to
be changed because it was written in c
plus plus this is now in c sharp also
there was no like entity component
system or any real api in that previous
version two years ago so
this needs to dramatically change but
all of the math that is kind of the
stuff that i'm interested in since that
dictates the actual like logic and feel
of the game rather than like the api and
all of that stuff which doesn't really
matter as you can see here i'm actually
taking some of the
values the same values that i used in
that game and plugging them in here we
can do this via the ui with the c public
variable of course just like in unity
and if we hit play there's our rocket
it's moving up with the spacebar and it
has its own kind of gravity that is
independent of the physics system
because we're actually setting the
rocket's position via the script now
next up i want the camera to follow the
rocket i'm going to do this by creating
a c-sharp script for the camera i'm
duplicating the existing script just to
make things a little bit faster since if
i create a new c-sharp file it's going
to be completely empty it's not going to
there's no template with the oncreate on
update function nothing like that so
this is just a little bit faster now i
could just parent the camera entity to
the rocket entity and that would satisfy
the whole like camera following the
rocket requirement but the reason why
i'm doing it in this script is because i
might want a little bit more control
over the way that the camera moves i
don't want to directly associate it with
the rocket so here i'm just finding the
rocket getting its translation and
setting up the camera's translation
based on that except for the z axis
because i want the camera to be of
course quite far from the rocket on that
axis here you can actually see how to
add a new script component to an entity
you actually have to type in the full
kind of name so in this case
rocket.camera as long as that class has
been compiled as part of the c-sharp dll
it will show up inside hazel and
everything will be good that's our
current workflow and to be honest i kind
of like it some auto complete would be
nice but i don't think there's any need
to really create scripts using the
editor ui if you're gonna then open them
in visual studio anyway i also added
this little kind of floor just so that
we can actually see what's going on
since the camera is moving with the
rocket which means it looks like nothing
is moving and as you can see the rocket
is now moving forward this is beginning
to feel a little bit like a tutorial so
i'm probably going to speed up some of
these next steps if you guys are
interested what i might do is make like
a full non-sped up version complete with
commentary and put that up somewhere
maybe on like a hazel engine channel but
for this video let's just keep it
concise after making the rocket rotate
to kind of face a direction based on its
velocity just like in the previous game
we more or less have the basic mechanic
done scale is always a challenging thing
when it comes to making games so you'll
see me kind of play around with the
rocket scale and all of that throughout
this video now i had an idea i thought
it would be cool if the rocket would
actually kind of spin around its y-axis
this didn't really make sense in the 2d
game of course but here why not so i
quickly added that in i also wasn't too
happy that the kind of emissive burner
wasn't really visible since we were at
like a 90 degree angle to the rocket so
i also added like a little bit of x
rotation so that it would kind of appear
as if the rocket wobbled this i think
was a cool effect regardless of that
burner after some more tweaking it's
time to add in those pillars now hazel
does have like a default cone shape that
we can use but i wanted to kind of make
this one a little bit more low poly a
little bit more simple and have that
option to modify it if i wanted to so i
made it in blender imported it and there
we have it i placed a couple in the
world just to see what it would look
like then i wanted to give them a
material i just decided on this green
color for now made sure that it had a
mesh collider and then i just created a
prefab out of it because the plan is
going to be to instantiate these via a
level script now inside the level script
i'm adding a public prefab field so that
we can then simply go back and drag in
that pillar into that c-sharp field so
that we can instantiate it and speaking
of which let's go back to the original
game from two years ago and steal some
more code now this part is actually
quite different because back then of
course no entity component system no
prefabs nothing everything was kind of
just in a data structure and then
rendered inside an on render function so
it really is quite different here but
the stuff that isn't different is the
math as i mentioned so like calculating
positions for the pillars spacing them
apart reusing the pillars again when the
rocket gets to a different part of the
level all of that stuff is more or less
the same but how do we convert that into
this ecs system well first of all we
don't really need a container to contain
all these kind of instantiated pillars
because we can just instantiate them as
children of this level entity that's
pretty cool because we already have that
kind of children data structure that
list of children which you can see me
using here and the rest of the code kind
of translates more or less the same way
now i have no idea about the scale of
these things because we were just
rendering them as like i think 2d quads
actually in that game two years ago but
we can always play around with the
numbers so for now i'm keeping them as
is and now if i hit play you can see we
have our pillars a little bit weird
position and the floor obviously is was
just there for reference so i'll need to
reposition some things maybe play with
the scale but more or less looks pretty
cool now it's feeling a little bit slow
almost kind of feels like we're
underwater so that definitely needs to
be fixed or underwater theme maybe now
if i zoom the camera out kind of hard to
do while playing you can actually see
that pillar reusing working which is
pretty cool it kind of looked like maybe
there weren't enough pillars because i
could kind of see them appearing
sometimes so i just added another pair
and here we have our first kind of
gameplay i guess looks pretty cool now
the next step is to create that floor
and ceiling pretty simple stuff we just
need to position them in the right place
make sure that they're big enough so
that it looks nice give them some names
and a material and then finally of
course we need them to follow the player
so that we never run out of them now
what i'm going to do here actually is
parent the ceiling to the floor that way
i only need to find the one floor entity
in the c-sharp script move that and then
of course since the ceiling is a child
it will also move and here we have
endless floor and ceiling and endless
pillars now one thing i'm not digging is
that this channel logo is a bit kind of
dark so what i'm actually going to do is
add some lighting because you know you
want that channel logo nice and visible
there we go much better now we
definitely want some kind of score
obviously to see what the score is so
funny thing about hazel is it doesn't
actually have any like ui you could say
we can rent a text but it is all kind of
in world space it's like an entity part
of the scene it's not going to be in
screen space i mean i guess you could
use some c sharp code and like you know
some math and all that to actually make
it effectively in screen space but hazel
doesn't really quite offer that yet it's
you know we're working on it but for
this game i actually think that's kind
of okay because what i'm gonna do is
just have the score hover above the
rocket we can also kind of push it back
so that it's behind the pillars i think
that'll look really cool besides modern
ui and games you know they like to do
this kind of stuff and i think it
definitely works for this game now as
for the score itself nothing really too
complicated here the pillars are all
evenly spaced apart so just like in the
original game the score is really just a
function of the rocket's x position i
also decided to get rid of the word
score so it looks cleaner now i kind of
forgot to add colliders to the floor and
ceiling so just quickly doing that here
and now we can actually make game over
happen so what i'm going to do is to the
rocket at a collision begin callback
which is basically a callback function
that gets called when we collide with
something with this given other entity
we don't really care what we collide
with at this point we're just going to
mark collided as true
and then the plan is in the on update
function we can handle that game over
which in this case will simply just
destroy this rocket entity
for certain reasons we don't want to
destroy it from within the collision
callback that's why i'm setting up this
collided boolean but you can see that
with that in place it works we can lose
the game we can't really respawn but
that's okay the rocket disappears when
we hit something great but not exactly
satisfying i feel like the rocket should
like i don't know crumble or something
wouldn't that be cool yeah it would so
let's go back to blender and fracture
this rocket i'm just using the cell
fracture add-on that is included as part
of blender this takes like a few goes to
get right i think because it somewhat
does it randomly and you might want to
tweak these parameters in addition to
that if geometry isn't like a certain
way it might not work so for example
it's like cylinder body is missing its
kind of top face so i'm adding it back
here so that we don't get that weird
piece generating also since dynamic like
mesh colliders need to be convex it's
important to make sure that you don't
have too much intersection of geometry
happening because then things will just
explode as you can see here so i'm
actually going to go back to blender
maybe space these out a little bit more
lots of tweaking i think this is
definitely going to be the part that
pushes me over an hour just because this
whole fracturing business you want to
take some time to get it right once i'm
more or less happy with it i'm going to
make a prefab out of it and then we can
simply instantiate that prefab with the
exact same transform as the original
rocket when we destroyed that original
rocket so we're really just pulling the
old switcheroo and hopefully no one will
notice and here we go testing it boom
now the pieces like just absolutely
explode outwards and again i think
that's probably because of the geometry
intersecting itself as i mentioned lots
of tweaking is necessary to get this
looking right i'm going to try my best
with a limited time i have available to
fix this up okay there we go i basically
just made some bigger pieces played with
the scale that kind of stuff and i
really like this effect of not really
exploding outwards but just kind of
crumbling i think it looks really cool
all right time for everyone's favorite
thing particles hazel still doesn't have
a particle system though but that's okay
because it's actually really easy to
write your own quick and dirty particle
system with this current setup
especially because we have instanced
rendering which means that we can render
a lot of an identical mesh what i'm
going to do is just create this kind of
empty particle emitter entity and put it
right where i want the particles to come
out of that way we can more or less just
instantiate the particles right at that
entity's transform now the first thing
that i wanted to do with my particle
system is set up like a little timer so
that i could basically emit a particle
that little smoke particle that's
supposed to pop out every now and then i
wanted to emit it basically every half
second so that's why i set the emit rate
to 0.5 i'm just going to write some
simple code here to basically
instantiate the particle and give it
some kind of transform what i'm going to
do here is obviously not parent the
particle to the rocket because i don't
want it to move with the rocket i'm
going to add it to like a smoke particle
container just so i can like keep track
of it and all of that and of course i
need to make sure that i instantiate it
like in world space not relative to this
rocket entity of course so that's why
i'm using the world transform of this
particle emitter entity i'm adding a
little bit of an impulse force in a
random direction just to give it some
movement and adding it to that smoke
particle container now let's actually
create the particle prefabs so that we
can instantiate them the original game
had square particles so it only makes
sense to make these cubes now i added a
box collider here to be honest i don't
know why i did that and i'll remove it
later but yeah just thought that would
be cool i guess so i hit play rocket
immediately explodes because it's
emitting the smoke particle which is
colliding with the rocket which is
causing it to explode
so
again instead of removing that box
collider i decided to go into the
project settings and add another physics
layer for the particles because i guess
for some reason i wanted the particles
to collide with each other but not with
like the default layer which is the
layer that the rocket is on again not
sure what happened to me here but yeah
and so now finally whoa why are there so
many there's supposed to be only one
every half second what is going on but
hey they're colliding with each other so
there's that and to be honest this looks
kind of cool especially with the
lighting coming from the burner i
decided to log the smoke timer to see if
anything was wrong and instead i was
greeted with a lot of
null reference exceptions now
our debugging isn't the greatest but
it's pretty easy to see where the null
reference exception is coming from and
of course if your script crashes then
the rest of that script is kind of more
or less ignored or at least that
function exits of course so therefore
the smoke timer was just always you know
zero i guess and we were emitting them
every frame so once we've fixed that up
by actually creating a smoke particle
container you can see we're emitting
these lovely smoke particles which i
think look pretty cool now let's make
them spin a little bit because they're
kind of still so we're going to add some
angular velocity to the rigid body and
there we go now they kind of spin cool
now let's do the same but for those kind
of glowing fire particles which i think
will look really cool for this i
actually want to get the rocket entity
get the rocket script so that we can
actually get the velocity of the rocket
and then emit those particles into the
opposite direction of the velocity that
way they'll basically be emitted out of
that burner which is the intention now
the reason i'm checking for rocket
entity being null a lot you may have
noticed that everywhere is because we do
actually destroy the rocket if we die so
it's possible for the rocket not to
exist and we just want to protect our
code from that so that it doesn't crash
i'm not going to bother making the
rocket actually emit the particles right
here in the emitter i'm just going to
check for the spacebar being pressed and
we will emit those particles of course
if the rocket is dead and null then no
particles will be emitted now let's
create that fire particle prefab give it
a nice emissive material and hey that
looks a little bit weird i mean i guess
it's working but they're like spinning a
lot why is that happening oh yeah it's
because they're literally being emitted
like on top of each other and they're
colliding and they're going crazy
because cherno added that box collider
for some reason before i abandoned my
box collider however i decided to tweak
some values because
maybe that's the reason i don't even
know why i did that to be honest always
fun watching these as like a little
postmortem reflection seeing yourself
being a comedian
and now finally removing the box
collider from the smoke particle
and from the fire particle there we go
that looks much better now although they
are kind of still so let's maybe give
them a bit more force maybe i misjudged
that yeah there we go that looks much
better now the other thing that i'm
noticing here is it kind of looks cool
when they get close to the pillars
because they're emissive but they're not
actually emitting light as i mentioned
so let's just add point lights to them
that'll be cool now you might be
thinking every particle with a point
light that is kind of expensive however
thanks to hazel using four plus
rendering it's actually pretty cheap
depends how many you have of course and
if they're overlapping but i think we've
only got a couple hundred at most here
so it should be fine i also decided to
change the pillar material to be
metallic because that way the specular
highlight from those fire particle
lights will just look a lot better all
right more tweaking that i'm definitely
not going to be too stressed about
thanks to the rules looking pretty good
however i think it would look even
cooler if the scene was a lot darker
since we have a lot of kind of emissive
stuff going on and based on the original
game the pillars are also well supposed
to glow i guess so maybe like a night
theme would suit this better now the
next thing that we really should do is
actually set up a particle system so to
speak because the problem is we are
spawning especially the fire particles
as we spawn a lot more of them than the
smoke particles they're kind of just
being spawned and never killed off
additionally we kind of lose the ability
to control them over time which is
something we might want to do we could
give each particle a c-sharp script but
let's be honest that's not great so
instead what i'm going to do is write
this little particle system script i've
actually set it up as an entity here
which isn't like strictly necessary but
the point is we're going to be able to
add each particle that we emit or at
least each fire particle that we emit
into this list which we can then like
manage and maybe scale down over time
and then once the life runs out then we
can destroy the particle entity and of
course nothing works the first time this
time though i'm going to actually check
the log to see what's going on and of
course another null reference exception
same problem i forgot the fire particle
container i should really just add them
both to like the particle system entity
but whatever guess we're doing
containers now that that's all fixed we
can see the particles getting smaller
over time and then dying and to be
honest i really love the effect of the
fire particle light on the smoke
particles i think that looks really cool
now back to the environment i don't
really dig this kind of generated sky
with the sunset or whatever is going on
here so i'm actually going to use
this environment map which you can
download for free from poly haven
blurring it looks very cool of course
and we get something slightly more
interesting i think
let's make those pillars change their
colors i'm going to go back to the
original game and grab this hsv to rgb
little conversion function and adapt it
into our c-sharp script getting those
default values as well from the original
game and then modifying the material now
because they all have the same material
i can actually just get like the first
child because they're all instantiated
under this level class the first child
which is the first pillar get its mesh
component and get the first material
from that mesh component now materials
are also a little bit interesting in
hazel in the sense that if you modify
them whilst playing the game then that
state it kind of remains so you'll see
me like stop this at times later on and
whatever the material was like when the
game ended when i hit the stop button it
kind of remains the same this is
completely okay for us here though
because of course we're actually setting
these parameters every time we play the
game so it's fine
now about that pillar glow we talked
about that both danny's game and my game
from two years back had as well let's
make the pillar material emissive
however i had this idea of progressively
making it more and more emissive so
every 10 score that we get basically i
wanted to suddenly jump up in brightness
i don't want this to be like a smooth
thing and i don't want them to remain
the same level of emission throughout
the game and of course as with the other
emissive material objects that we have
in the scene i also want this to emit
light so i'm going to add a point light
to each pillar now this also means that
the
color of the point light and its
intensity should probably go hand in
hand with the pillar color and the
pillar's emission so i'm also going to
set that up through the c-sharp script
the floor and ceiling is kind of looking
all dark and depressing so i'm also
going to add the pillow material to
those and there we have it we basically
have a more or less finished game here's
some beautiful sped up gameplay going as
far as i can i really wanted to kind of
test the emission here to see just how
bright it would get but i think it's
pretty manageable
and i got all the way up to 102
i think it looks really cool until we
disable bloom that is there are those
materials persisting as i mentioned
now as i played this and i got all the
way up to 102 i realized that it the
game is kind of very repetitive
obviously and there's no real challenge
you could just probably keep doing that
forever so i wanted to add some kind of
speed up to the rocket because of course
if the rocket gets faster over time
eventually you will just die
my first test of this proved that it
just it just sped up way too quickly i
wanted to look at the actual velocity
value here and i did and i realized it
was just too much so i went back to the
script and just made it 10 times slower
and to be honest the game's feeling kind
of nice
now two years ago hazel didn't have any
audio system whatsoever and now we
actually have quite a good one so whilst
i'm not going to pull a dany and somehow
manage to write music within the one
hour i would love to do that by the way
for an extended version of this game but
definitely not now sound effects however
using bfxr let's make that happen the
first one i wanted was some kind of
explosion for when the rocket hits
something
putting that into hazel is pretty
straightforward and we actually have
quite a lot of parameters to play with
i'm not going to bother with any of that
here though we're really quite tight on
time let's just make it play and the
simplest way i can think of to make it
play is just play on awake for the
fractured rocket because of course
that's what we instantiate when we hit
something beautiful now we have no way
of restarting the game from within the
game but it's okay we're gonna just
shove that under the rug i also thought
it would be cool to have a little spawn
sound yep definitely cool
[Music]
i think it's nice having these kind of
8-bit sound effects with these kind of
graphics speaking of which the font is
really not doing it for me either for
the score so i went on dafont.com to try
and find some free font to use
slapping that into hazel and playing
around with the color and the size and
all of that i think we have a pretty
cool result one of the reasons why i
decided to make it black by the way is
because obviously it gets very bright
with all of that emission later on in
the game so i wanted to always make that
font visible the text by the way is not
affected by lighting or anything like
that because it's kind of 2d and it's
actually rendered on a separate layer
you could say in a separate render pass
so nothing to worry about there we also
had this one little null reference
exception as a result of again something
trying to use the rocket when the rocket
had already been destroyed so i
rearranged this script a little bit to
be easier to read and make more sense
and also fix that bug i also realized
that in the fractured rocket i never
actually set up that burner material so
i went through all of those fractured
pieces and added in that material so
yeah game looks pretty dope i think
especially with that font here's some
beautiful gameplay
[Music]
now the one thing that i kind of didn't
like is that the score was sometimes way
hidden behind a pillar and it was like
impossible to see this is obviously a
problem so i had this idea of just
animating it to go into like the center
of the screen or around about that area
so that after you die you could actually
see the score since there's that huge
gap in the middle adding that was pretty
straightforward and after some tweaking
i think it looks pretty cool and that's
it i'm gonna leave this game here i
really would love to take some more time
and extend this all in all what i've
done right here took me around an hour
and 25 minutes
well that was pretty easy
that's because i didn't actually make
the game now i made it like before i
recorded the first part of the video
is that cheating this is youtube let's
get real so i think the cool part about
the video that you guys just watched is
that whilst it of course is sped up in
certain areas
i actually didn't cut anything every
single action that i took whether that
be code that i wrote or changed or
buttons that i clicked inside hazel's
editor every single action was actually
shown in that video so theoretically if
you slow it down
that's a full-on tutorial that being
said what i think i'm going to do is on
a separate like hazel engine channel i
will actually play the real time version
of this video and i might kind of talk
about everything that i'm doing and
effectively turn that into a tutorial
that might be interesting for people who
want to make games in hazel or just see
like what hazel is like because i think
that's quite interesting it's almost
like a director's commentary considering
it's my engine as you can see hazel has
come a long way in the last two years
and i'm even more excited for the future
if you want to support hazel and get
access to all of the source code the
actual engine that i use to make this
game then head over to
patreon.com if you sign up with at least
a 10 per month tier you will get access
to all of this source code and you will
be able to make this same game and also
see all the source code behind the
engine patreon is the platform that we
use to fund this project if we didn't
have you patreon supporters then i
wouldn't be able to hire people i
wouldn't be able to support myself and
my family i wouldn't be able to make all
of these videos so basically i'm saying
that hazel would not exist if it wasn't
for you guys and for that i am eternally
grateful i really want to release this
game for you guys but hazel doesn't
exactly have a way to release games at
the moment we can play games in the
runtime so in other words we can
actually play it as a standalone
application but the problem is there is
no packaging of assets there is
like a lot of the engine internals are
kind of exposed it's a little bit messy
to actually distribute games i guess my
point is we can play games standalone
but we can't really distribute games in
the way that i would like to so what i'm
going to do is this i have a final
patron tier called partner there are
around 50
generous supporters sitting in that tier
who have not received any rewards other
than the ones they would have gotten if
they were at the 10 tier the supporter 3
tier but they've been there they've been
there supporting hazel so what i'm going
to do is initially i'm going to release
this entire game for those partners so
if you are a partner patreon supporter
send me a message on patreon and i'll
hook you up i'll give you this game and
you'll be able to open it up in hazel
and play it right now and that's kind of
going to be the reward for partner
supporters from now on any games that we
make in hazel you guys will get the full
source access to the games the assets
all of that stuff and you'll be able to
open up that project within hazel
however i do still obviously want to
release the game for free for you guys
to play just for fun but as i mentioned
we're just not quite there yet with
hazel so what i'm going to be doing over
the next like couple months or so it
might be difficult because of like the
holiday season but i'm going to be
basically working as hard as i can to
create this kind of distribution side of
hazel so that we can actually shift this
game once that is done i'm going to
upload it for free onto like hio or
something like that so my point is you
guys will be able to play this game for
free but just not right now and believe
me i'm super excited to actually
officially ship like the first game made
in hazel i mean to be honest this is the
first you could say complete game that
i've made in hazel but before i do that
i had so much fun making this game and
there's still so many ideas that i
actually have that i think i might just
keep working on it let me know if you
guys want to see me continue working on
this game and just make it better i mean
like i really want to make like a main
menu screen maybe a way to submit high
scores or something like that christmas
is coming up so maybe we want like a bit
of a christmas themed version if you
guys want to see that then definitely
drop a comment below and let me know but
other than that i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe to the channel if you are new
it's been an amazing year and i'm so
proud of all of the work that we've done
and as i mentioned i can't wait for the
next year and the year after that and
all the amazing stuff we're going to be
able to create don't forget to check out
hosting using the link below have an
absolutely fantastic holiday season and
i will see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you